okay I'm gonna talk about DC again but I
promise I'm not gonna yell this time so
a couple of things have happened in
regards to Warner Brothers and DC Comics
related movies the the first one the big
news is that Matt Reeves after having
been in talks then leaving talks
apparently because things got heated and
now has apparently come back and is
signed confirm to direct the Batman and
actually this is the first bit of news
to come out in relation to DC movies
that gives me a little bit of hope not
so much in that I'm putting that much
faith in Matt Reeves specifically I like
him as a director and I I hope he does
well but I mean it's not like he's gonna
single-handedly just revive the thing
for me but here's what gives me some
hope when he had left talks the report
and the word was that he had left
because things got heated and maybe come
back quote-unquote when cooler heads
prevailed or something along those lines
now that says that things just you know
things got passionate which is I mean
it's good to have someone who's
passionate but what it says to me the
fact that he's now signed that means
somebody blinked because initially he
left talks and that means he and Warner
Brothers weren't seeing eye-to-eye and
they had to step away if they're now in
an agreement
somebody caved and somebody gave in to
the other side and if I were to guess
it's probably Warner Brothers could
simply put Matt Reeves on the heat that
he's getting off of the Apes movies
and/or the Planet of the Apes looks
great so I don't expect that heat to die
down he doesn't need this gig so if he
feels it's not worth it for him to do it
he would just walk so that to me says if
he's back and signed that Warner
Brothers were the ones that gave in to
whatever his demands were now I have no
way of knowing what those demands were
but I would suspect it would be if not
final cut at least some guarantee that
the movie would not be completely taken
out of his hands at any point now if
Warner Brothers is willing to make those
kinds of capitulations that to me is a
good sign it's not a complete 180 from
the kind of management just mess that I
think they've been doing up to this
point but it's a step in a correct
direction that is in the interest of the
finished product not just the interest
of the bottom line and
as a change from what we normally see
warner brothers doing and that is a good
thing again I'm not doing a 180 on my
stance on Warner Brothers and everything
else but I am gonna say you know what
gives me a little bit of hope now the
other big Batman related news is that
Chris McKay is apparently I think he's
still in talks at least at the time I'm
recording this to direct a Nightwing
movie now
Chris McKay directing it is is a choice
that both makes sense and is weird it
makes sense in standards sort of studio
progressing somebody up the ranks logic
he just directed Lego Batman for them
like a Batman has done very well well
received well reviewed made tons of
money and so they're like we want you to
keep doing stuff with us here's it
here's another project for you but I
mean Chris McKay is an animation guy and
a comedy animation guy at that so what
about Nightwing is slightly odd it would
seem to indicate that maybe they're
willing to lighten up the world and that
if they did look Nightwing it would be
of a lighter tone that's I mean that
supposition on my part maybe Chris McKay
has a darker story that he wants to tell
I mean heck Jordan peels known as the
comedy guy and get out in G so I don't
want to jump too much on what it says
about the tone of Nightwing but I mean I
like Chris McKay's work where it strikes
me as odd is the idea of a Nightwing
movie for a character who hasn't been
introduced you know I'm not saying that
they have to cede characters who are
gonna get their own movies somewhere
else first but Nightwing is so
intrinsically tied to Batman the idea
that they are going for a Nightwing
project when we don't even know if
Nightwing is gonna appear in the Batman
solo movie just strikes me as weird and
the other thing that's weird about doing
a Nightwing movie is the movies and not
honestly not just the movies but the
movies most glaringly really seem to
have gone out of their way to avoid
Robin at all costs there's been and and
it alleges that it's not restrictive the
movies really since about the mid
eighties almost everything Batman
related has gone out of its way to
minimize Robin unless they feel they
really wanted for specific stories with
things like Damian Wayne who Grant
Morrison obviously had a very specific
plan in mind for that character but by
and large even when Damian Wayne was
around
most of the Batman comics that I read he
was going solo the idea Batman as this
loner is really sort of wet it's that's
the image they push at this point and
you know the kid running around and the
yellow green red it kind of it people
think it's goofy and it is to a certain
extent but I mean that I mean Batman
Batman was originally for kids and but
Robert is an aspect that they really
kind of shunted off to the side and it
concerns me slightly that they would
jump to Nightwing without having done
Robin and this sort of also speaks to my
feelings about people have been calling
for the under the Red Hood storyline and
I don't I'm not the biggest fan of that
storyline in the first place but I
really don't want to see it in
live-action if we don't have some
context for it if we haven't actually
seen a Robin like the idea that anything
related to Robin was just a backstory
that we're never gonna actually see
that's gotta take a lot of the weight
out of the proceedings with anything
that you're gonna wear the character is
rooted in having been Robin at some
point whether it's related to the Red
Hood storyline or it's related to
Nightwing or any of that other stuff but
it's it's early days and you know maybe
there's a plan I I don't know I I'm
still sceptical of Warner Brothers on
the whole but like I said the fact that
Mary Yves is signed that's the first
indication I'm like okay it's a step in
the right direction so I'm not gonna go
like bye doesn't matter no it doesn't
matter that's a step in the right
direction and it gives me a little bit
of hope for that specific project it
doesn't alter my feelings and my
concerns about Wonder Woman or Justice
League or the flash or any of the stuff
that's already been cooking away but it
it may may fingers crossed point to
further down the line maybe they're
getting some corrective measures laid
out as opposed to flying by the seat of
their pants and trying to fix things in
the middle of production like they did
with Suicide Squad so that's my thoughts
on the latest news to come out in
relation to DC movies Batman
specifically what are your thoughts on
that Reeves being confirmed what are
your thoughts on a Nightwing movie what
kind of storyline would you like to see
Nightwing be involved in if you were to
be given a solo movie whatever your
thoughts are drop something down to calm
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks check out the council
of geeks podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned